Kitty hé hé
Kitty
oh tu vas bien
je faisais encore ce truc n'était-ce pas
ouais tu étais je me souviens d'avoir déjeuné
avec Jim il a commencé à parler de ce
genre de fille de la forêt qui avait un
don spécial de connexion avec les êtres vivants
et elle va  avoir environ 14 ans et toi
et moi savons à quel point tu es immature donc je
pense que tu peux gérer ça j'ai dit Merci
quand tu vois Sigourney un personnage qui a le
quart de son âge réel parfaitement elle s'est
imprégnée des manières des
adolescentes salut maman mais inconsciemment  elle est juste
devenue plus jeune c'était fou d'observer
pourquoi je ne peux pas être comme tout le monde
Je ne pense pas qu'aucun d'entre nous ne soit très
loin de nous-mêmes de 14 ans
c'est un souvenir si fort à quel point c'était génial
et à quel point c'était horrible  était et je suis juste
tombé amoureux du personnage Jim a
cette incroyable capacité à écrire directement
dans le cœur d'un personnage pourquoi suis-je
différent la capture de performance donne aux
acteurs la possibilité de jouer des
personnages qu'ils ne pourraient pas
jouer autrement et Kyrie '  Le personnage de
Sigourney et la performance de Sigourney sont l'
exemple parfait de celui donné par l'une des
grandes actrices de notre époque,
ils l'ont emmené J'ai dû travailler
complètement différemment de ce que j'ai jamais fait
auparavant parce que vous devez enlever
tout ce Sigourney Weaver
est et ce fut une
expérience incroyable de remonter dans le temps et d'être
avec cette personne chaque jour, elle clique
sur le personnage qu'elle est et c'est
comme parler à une jeune fille de 14 ans, je trouve
fascinant qu'elle puisse canaliser cette
jeune fille quoi que ce soit  J'aime le regarder
battre son cœur comme
[Musique]
Puissante
elle est merveilleuse de la regarder c'est une telle
œuvre d'art que vous regardez comme une
fleur se dérouler et tout d'un coup vous ne
reconnaissez pas que vous parlez à une
femme qui est  5 10.
qui a marché sur cette Terre pendant des décennies
et qui a fait sa marque là-bas est si clairement une
petite fille espiègle à Sigourney,
elle peut être aussi impérieuse que vous le souhaitez et
elle peut aussi être un crétin
étranger
c'est  un grand voyage pour elle et pour le
public avec elle parce que ça va
parce qu'elle se soucie d'elle elle a une
qualité lumineuse de la voir jouer un
gamin de 14 ans c'était magique
c'est ce qu'est le jeu Avatar est le seul moyen de
faire le tour
[Musique  ]